connected to this another very famous
and well-known demon in this context is
Pazuzu this is quite interesting because
while Pazuzu certainly has a frightening
appearance and some incantations do
describe him as the king of the evil
wind demons he was mostly used as a
protective Spirit particularly against
lashu Pazuzu really looks like a monster
he has the head of a beast with long
claws and four wings but the figure of
this demon would be employed as
protection his head would often be worn
by pregnant women to keep lashu away
from their unborn child and a statue of
him could be kept in the house or used
in rituals for the same reason quite the
opposite of his role in The Exorcist in
other words aside from these two
prominent characters we also have other
more ambiguous kinds of demons or
creatures that roam the lands of
Mesopotamia